this December Mercedes is rolling out at
sea kupe the sportiest version of the
c-class the most powerful c-class coupe
a the c300 comes with a 2 liter 4
cylinder engine that puts out up to 180
kilowatts above nman hook but our
current estimate is current wants a
sporty ride and this engine will provide
it get nokia nablus mid-season motor
young it's a 4-liter v8 twin
turbocharged gasoline engine in the AMG
c63s model it's chock full of decibels
and chock full of fun of course you
can't really let it rip on a country
road so Martha says he'll head for the
famous askari racetrack which is not far
away that is d balloon Tosca Viren
striker onstar Vadim against Malin begin
but before we open it up on the
racetrack let's take a closer look at
this brawny sports coupe a all that the
AMG version retains from the much more
reserved production model is the doors
roof and trunk lid the extremely wide
fender broadens the AMG coupe a by six
centimeters
taking its cue from motorsports Mercedes
has reduced the interior to the
essentials in the S version the v8 twin
turbo as a maximum torque of 700 Newton
meters and a breathtaking sound
on the way to the Ascari track we
already get an impression of the cars
handling and how impressively it
accelerates
other buddy miles Montes cautions that
the AMG demands a sensitive foot on the
gas pedal even if the road is dry if you
accelerate to powerfully out of a curve
you feel the muscular torque on the rear
axle what I
montes likes the tight steering not at
all like Mercedes typically squishy
middle range the AMG has a real sports
color feel
sada effing Montes doesn't like the
gearshift lever on the steering column
it may be typical for Mercedes but it
doesn't really belong in an AMG model
another lever adjust the suspension to
any driving situation whether country
road or racetrack unlike the production
version of the c-class coupe a says
Montes the AMG variants dynamic selector
offers no fuel saving eco mode just
sport Sport Plus and race as
alternatives to the comfort mode soon
come four motors on 58 slice will be an
askari in a jiffy and Montes can't wait
to shift to race mode it reduces the
effect of the electronic stability
control and makes the engine more
aggressive as you can hear the flaps
near the exhaust pipe or open wide and
the engine really roars Montes is afraid
the noise would give him a headache on
long hauls but it's fine on the
racetrack the Ascari race resort is not
an ordinary racetrack it combines
replicas of segments of legendary
racetracks in one course so it's ideal
for taking the mercedes AMG c63s kupe to
its limits even a beginner can have fun
with a sport coupe a
matta sleeves testing the cars limits to
the professional racing drivers in race
mode the ESP is restricted letting the
driver drift around curves
what all of my Montes is enthusiastic
about the engine and about the brakes
whose power he says kept him out of
trouble several times on the track
there's taking a bleep haba he reckons
said it would take practice to keep up
with the professionals with this vehicle
in askari hizmet Arden con that what's
not on this year in an octazooka
Mohammed a man undulate Zimmerman says
if you're looking for a midsize car with
cutting-edge technology in great design
try the infiniti q50 it was first
launched on the market back in 2013 so
it's not exactly new but the infiniti
q50 is still a real headturner and it's
surprisingly quiet that's thanks to the
hybrid drive
you
but the infiniti q50 has more surprises
to offer that definitely set it apart
from its rivals one of the larger and
more noticeable ones can be found inside
I trinath the time in a nice detail in
the cabin is that you have two screens
the top one is reserved for either the
around view camera system or the GPS but
then below you can still see say how
much feel you are using thoughts them
not somebody football staton on siding
nothing when it comes to the exterior
the shape may not stand out so much but
the lines are sleek and then there's
those sickle-shaped LED headlights the
unmistakable gaze as infinity calls it
that certainly give the car presence and
radiates a raw power not something you
necessarily expect from a fuel economic
hybrid
the same signature lights also grace the
rear the capacity of the trunk is
limited just 300 litres that's
definitely a weakness in the Japanese
car compared with its European rivals
the hybrid drive is noticeably sporting
designed above all for speed a high
performer that's certainly enjoyable to
drive space may be lacking in the truck
but the Infinity makes up for it in the
cabin with a generous amount of space
for passengers the q50 comes with three
drivers that are sold on the European
market there's the diesel and petrol
engines and then there's the gasoline
hybrid version which is the one we're
testing
it offers 268 kilowatts and can power
from 0 to 100 kilometers an hour in just
5.1 seconds thanks to the electric motor
top speed is 250 kilometers an hour and
fuel economy six point two liters that
okay one thing Andre likes is the mental
shift pedals on the q50 the only
drawback is that they have plastic
finishing that's quite sharp on the
edges delight Asif accountant hob the
q50 has three different drive settings
standard sport and eco and that's not
all you can also choose your own
settings in ninety six different
categories allowing the car to be
tailored to the individual needs of the
driver in the Eco mode those who find
the Eco setting a little too tame can
switch to sports mode the q50 then
sounds really good and it certainly
moves the steering also becomes tighter
and more direct for Andre's taste it's a
little too tight but even then there's a
solution you can select individual mode
and adjust the settings to what you want
individual models that come and also
understand me mad sometimes not
the interior feels luxurious and
inviting the double screen center
console is the definite highlight the
infotainment system is operated by
touchpad or if you prefer by voice
command the multifunctional steering
wheel includes cruise control as
standard for the first time the leather
appointed upholstery also helps to give
a high quality feel the letter Q plays
an important role in infinities
philosophy the first infinity model was
the q45 the q50 was designed to hail the
start of a new distinctly sporty series
the q50 is pretty [ __ ] but infinity is
not doing so well in Germany first
there's the high starting price around
fifty three thousand euros for the
hybrid version compared with a plug-in
hybrid like the Passat GTE that goes for
just forty four thousand even worse
Germany currently has only six dealers
who offer infinity unbeaten so the q50
has plenty to offer but if infinity
really wants to power ahead in Europe a
few changes may be needed
the lexus RX has been very popular in
the united states since it came out in
1998 its newest generation is targeting
the german market as well the new
edition has more advanced engines
state-of-the-art safety packages and
unprecedented comfort the basic model
starts at fifty one thousand two hundred
fifty euros in germany volvo will unveil
its s90 in january 2016 at the north
american international auto show in
detroit footage of the new premium sedan
in action has already been released the
new volvo s90 has a semi autonomous
driving assistant that subtly intervenes
in steering to keep the car on track at
speeds from zero to 130 km/h a further
step toward fully automated driving the
s90 will hit showrooms in summer 2016
individually Tate everyone wants to set
himself apart from the crowd says our
car tester I know Dyson hope on the Opel
Adam provides plenty of individualism
with many different roof and chassis
colors and special interior details but
of course a modern subcompact has to be
practical and thrifty as well a modern
three-cylinder engine needs to provide
respectable power with low fuel
consumption we tested the Opel Adam with
the one liter Ecotec direct injection
engine which comes in two versions
producing 66 485 kilowatts we tested the
more powerful version opel says it gets
100 kilometers on 5.1 liters of gasoline
the atom has received many awards for
its design with all the
individualization options the car is
two-tone paint scheme makes it an eye
catcher the roof seems like a Sun sale
stretched over the body consumers are
attracted to the model variants like the
convertible version and the crossover
Adam rocks
fox i'll give it open i note says sub
compacts like the opel adam are
conceived for inner-city use so the
Adams turning radius could have been a
little tighter but the Flex fixed system
that opal developed especially to
transport bicycles is very practical a
little drawer you can pull out of the
rear will hold a bike weighing up to 30
kilograms and an optional adapter will
carry a second bike the Adams flex fixed
system costs 590 euros the adapter for
the second bicycle is another 200 euros
the atom thereby combines a high degree
of practicality with an attractive
design that's quite a plus point because
car buyers often have to choose either
functionality or looks
the addams interior design offers a
wealth of individual design options not
only colors but also patterns pep up the
dashboard and the IntelliLink
infotainment system lets you link your
cell phone with the vehicle
how individual does your car need to be
the opel adam has colored clips on the
wheel rims stars on the roof playful
patterns on the dashboard and ten
different colors of interior lighting
but to show your car after a few years
you'll need to find a buyer who has
similar taste on duskin didn't really
sign so I'm pass only his fon psychic
and in months bring him the circuit de
Barcelona is the venue for the season
final of the sea at Lyon eurocup the one
made touring car series began in two
thousand eight competitors Dr C at
Leone's with two liter 4-cylinder turbo
engines the season comprises seven race
meetings with two races at each meeting
each race is 50 to 60 kilometres last
year's winner polo south is expecting
the final to be tough
I think this the championship is a is a
great championship there are a lot of
drivers the main drivers are very
competitive aggressive all of them want
to want to win so it is very difficult
arrive in the problem if you want to
stay in the podium you have to fight
paul rozelle of spain in norway sty and
paulson were running neck and neck with
72 points each as they started the final
race for the title
three men from Germany have come to
watch the final they're actually
professional actors but their dream is
to have a career in racing professional
racecar driver Sebastian style says he
knows they've all earned their basic
racing license but that's just the start
he suggests they all go watch the race
on this great track tom beck has already
had some experience with a real racing
car he trained under sebastian style to
get his initial license
it's what the I meet up tom says one of
his first training sessions was driving
a cup racer finding himself alone on the
track where the cup racer was probably a
once-in-a-lifetime experience and pretty
cool and then he did his license in
mending Germany that's far too much
cooler on done and many still attends
kamat Seemandhra has also done a few
rounds on the racetrack with Sebastian
on the legendary Nurburgring north loop
no less
dummy ID so they have their first basic
license they know what the different
flags mean and a few other things now
they need to start qualifying for small
races so they need to compete and be
among the first five to finish the race
then they get their extended license and
so they weren't from race to race and
series two series which of course become
increasingly international and get
various licenses until at some stage
they hopefully get a top license and
then they can take part in the really
really big races in fallon olivan soda
machine intense mr. Sood Anupam oliveto
against old and it's sensible comment
was identified Garrett Klein has also
received training from Sebastian star he
says acting and racing it more in common
than you'd think they both involve
concentration so Garrett feels well
prepared I think he says he's learned
how to study the racetrack Sebastian
looks at everything closely he studies
each bend in the track and asked what
speed does he need going into which Bend
Garrett says acting is no different he
prepares his roles thinks his way into
his character time will tell whether
Tom's Iman and Garrett have a future in
professional motorsport in the meantime
they can learn plenty and events like
this they watch paul rozelle
successfully defend his title in
barcelona and hope that one day they
could be in his place
it has the aerodynamic contours we'd
expect of a Porsche the differential
lock and Bradley flared fenders hint at
a sporting pedigree it features
lightweight construction and a low
center of gravity but this Porsche is no
sports car it's a tractor danza artistic
Gustav Bauer made sure to get detailed
instructions on how to start a Porsche
jr. first you engage the hand throttle
then push a switch forward down by the
engine to open the flow of fuel you
climb aboard don't push the key in if
its cold you have to preheat the engine
but that's not the case now then you
pull the ignition switch and off it goes
as early as 1937 the prolific designer
fatten on Porsche started developing a
people's tractor alongside the people's
car the volkswagen beetle by 1956 the
Porsche company was offering a range of
four tractor models with varying power
output and numbers of cylinders the
starting model was the single cylinder
jr. other products Christoph is thrilled
with his Porsches top speed of 19.9
kilometers an hour as long as no sheep
are in the way also available are two
and three cylinder models and even the
four-cylinder Porsche diesel master with
an amazing top speed of 27 kilometers an
hour porsche diesel moto and bow and
fleet examine ruled out some 120,000
tractors from nineteen fifty six to
nineteen sixty three
the days Formula One elite were seated
prominently on the Porsche junior for
advertising effect by 1957 the year
after the junior de beauté Porsche
diesel had achieved the zenith of its
success with the second highest number
of new tractors registered in Germany
positi Christophe says at the time
porsche stressed ease of operation after
all farmers wives and children ought to
be able to handle it and in fact they
could back then the oil hydraulic clutch
was absolutely high-tech and made
shifting easy at least shifting up
shifting down was harder because the
driver had to engage the clutch then the
throttle and then re-engaged the clutch
beam is a glass and when done class came
on Tommy the guy
traditionally all porsche tractors were
painted Carmen red an elegant design
right down to the detail set new optical
standards
omani attention Christophe hesitates to
describe a lowly piece of farm equipment
as beautiful in the classical sense but
he sees the proportions and the
wonderfully curved nose as exceptionally
well done it quickly acquired its own
fans who lovingly nicknamed the Porsche
junior red nose the junior itself was
available in three variations long short
and narrow narrow was for wine growers
the short Porsche junior was specially
conceived for farms with steep slopes
and lots of green fields in other words
the perfect lawn mower yeah a Porsche
junior is made up of some 2,000 well
thought-out and expertly designed and
machine parts the advanced hydraulic
clutch demands gratifyingly little from
the drivers muscles
the engineers place the drive for the
more right between the axles additional
implements can be hitched onto the tow
ball on the rear when Co Kristoff lifts
the gracefully curved nose to inspect
the single cylinder 14 horsepower diesel
engine with 822 ccs he describes it as a
genuine pioneer and lightweight
construction since the engine and
transmission casing are cast entirely
out of a special aluminum silicon alloy
silliman it also has no fan belts which
make it more robust and helps cut down
on maintenance the modular concept that
Porsche engineer Karl raba developed
allowed a choice of one two three or
four cylinder engines power sees it as
ingenious and typically Porsche
the gear reduction of differential lock
make for 2 x 3 forward gears and enable
the Porsche jr. to handle the roughest
terrain Christophe says the original
brochure stressed the wonderful
visibility on all sides hardly unusual
in a tractor but a day's work with this
thin steering wheel could leave a
farmer's hand calloused and the only
shock absorber is a spring under the
seat so trundling over the fields on it
could get pretty bumpy even so this
tractor was the most advanced of its
time the advertising slogan said Porsha
diesel built for the future so the
future belonged to Porsche diesel
advanced or not Porsche diesel halted
its tractor production in 1963 the
German market was flooded with cheaper
machines made by foreign competitors
Christophe muses that if the Porsche
diesel junior people's tractor had never
existed German farmers might still be
plowing their fields with horses and
oxen this all-round machine is robust
and easy to maintain at 25,000 units it
was the best-selling tractor of its time
and definitely a milestone in automotive
history i inspired out to a bigger city
much like the pioneering VW Beetle and
porsche 356 also with air-cooled engines
the porsche diesel jr set new standards
for its time
you